returning now to our breaking news story
out of the uk that we were reporting on
earlier in the conservative mp david
amis being stabbed multiple times let's
bring in nadeem baba in london nadeem
what do we know happened
well fully we know that um this member
of the conservative party member of
parliament
since 1983
in fact
was stabbed several times uh while he
was holding what they call a
constituency surgery a chance for
members of the public to present
problems and questions to their
representative this was happening in a
church in leon sea which is just a few
kilometers from the town of south end in
southeastern england on the coast
david
amos who's 69
was
treated at the scene there are quotes in
the local newspaper
from people who saw a man run into that
church and now we have heard from the
police that they have arrested one man
and they are not looking for anybody
else we've also heard from a local uh
counsellor a local politician there who
saw uh mr amos being treated for his uh
injuries saying that he didn't know what
condition he was in but that it didn't
look good
naturally there there has been an
outpouring in the last hour or so from
politicians on all sides here in the uk
um and it has reminded people of the
dangers that politicians do sometimes
face
when they are meeting
the public
in 2016 a labor member of parliament joe
cox was shot dead when she was holding a
similar meeting
uh where she uh in the town uh that she
actually represented and that was just a
few days before the brexit uh referendum
which had polarized uh opinions
and going back further in 2010 another
labour politician was uh attacked at a
constituency surgery lots of people uh
hoping that um that um david amos's
condition is not in fact
life-threatening we do not have word on
exactly his current state and we'll keep
a close eye on the story uh with you
nadine for the moment thank you very
much nadine baba live there in london